hey how's it going hey that's enough you
see him relaxed here yeah I like the
mountain bike I actually don't even like
wearing clothes anymore yeah Jason Momoa
the fans have noticed
go on
I really just shouldn't relax that's
about the extent of huh my workouts the
Aquaman star Graces the cover of men's
health and then boxing's always fun just
to kind of stay keep my cardio up
inviting the mag to his personal gym
assistant my fridge where Jason can just
be Jason hey how's it going
that's enough looks like you're living
the dream yeah
I would have got dressed up it's very
bizarre what I like to do
is I sit here and I just try to move all
these with my mind like that was
standing up once and then they were in
order
and and that one was over there and that
was up there but just like
use my mental Powers but the main
takeaway here hands down it's that Jason
has no problem bike riding in the buff
oh cool you see him relaxed here yeah
to go downhill what are some of your
favorite exercises to do at the gym I
travel kettlebells to help me with my
core and just like fighting and doing
stunts
yup no doubt the gym came in handy while
preparing for his Showdown with Dom
Toretto the thing about Jesus he was
trying to do something that was unique
to The Fast and Furious and that excites
me and that excites everybody I think
Ben will be fun we're gonna get like a
you and Vin Throwdown action scene maybe
I'm sure that's probably why they hired
me the great Dom Toretto if you never
would have gotten behind that wheel
I'd never be the man I am today there's
something Charming about him you know
what I mean like he does everything with
a with a with a smirk you know what I'm
saying and like there's something really
cute about that can you describe just
that he's hot maybe I'm just thrown off
because he's so he's not lying this is
your last ride
Batman
then you might want to buckle up you'll
see when you see the movie he comes in
with such a fresh and unique
approach a take on playing the classic
villain constantly trying to defy
expectations and as we now know expect
the unexpected when it comes to Jason
Momoa
I would have got dressed up that was the
time of my life
foreign